foreign
the village of Yellow Springs Ohio has
officially approved Dave Chappelle's
plans to turn what used to be a
firehouse into his own state-of-the-art
Comedy Club oh there's gonna be a poll
over the stage I don't know when asked
about the reasoning behind opening his
own club in Yellow Springs Chappelle
said quote a lot of local talent wants
to climb the ladder and there are people
who are trying to make it but can't
because of a lack of places to perform
I'm trying to make a way for our local
talents to be showcased as well as my
friend's talents he then went on to
mention the potential for some of the
biggest names in comedy to come visit
his new place saying quote if we build
this thing the greats will come and this
wouldn't be the first time Dave
Chappelle is convinced a bunch of Big
Time comedians to come up and perform
with him in Ohio back in 2020 Dave put
on a series of shows in Yellow Springs
during the pandemic called Chappelle's
summer camp which at the time were some
of the only live stand-up shows
happening anywhere on Earth it did the
camp Chappelle think this past weekend
out in Yellow Springs Ohio and uh I had
an amazing time got out there Wednesday
brought the whole family got tested
before I got on the plane got tested
afterward you know went out Wednesday I
wasn't supposed to be on the show jumped
on that show I just had a great time it
was such an amazing mix of just
comedians rappers poets musicians the
whole thing and I just felt like
everybody was sort of pushing each other
just had a great time and I really want
to thank Dave he was so ridiculously
generous to myself my family everybody
involved and it was so much fun to be
doing stand up getting laughs and and
there was like no phones everybody's
phone was locked and it was a level of
freedom and stand up that I have not
felt
since white female comedians have
started complaining much like Joe Rogan
Dave Chappelle's someone who cares
deeply about the craft of stand-up and
is willing to use his own personal
resources to directly improve the comedy
landscape forever whether that means
flying comics in and testing crowds
during covid or in this case opening his
very own 120-seat room yeah having him
come out and checking this out and then
he's like dude now I'm inspired so
whatever he's gonna do in Yellow Springs
can be very interesting because it's I
think he's doing 120 seats holy [__] if
he's doing a size the size of little boy
damn dude yeah imagine that like you can
go see Dave Chappelle at any given night
in his backyard what a great idea though
like he's Dave Chappelle he could do
that anywhere like why not why not like
build your own club and have the people
come to you because of course they're
going to come to see Dave it'll be a
vacation destination like like your Club
is people were from all over the world
last night at kill Tony one of the main
reasons that the village of Yellow
Springs Ohio was so quick to embrace
Dave Chappelle is that he's always
willing to put his money where his mouth
is like showing up to their Village
Council meetings and actually speaking
on his own behalf especially the
meetings that's centered around the
continuation of his summer camp shows
and the opening of this club
I just want to say I don't know why the
Village Council will be afraid of
litigation from a 24 million dollar a
year company well it's out the 65
million a year company I cannot believe
you would make me audition for you you
look like clowns I am not bumping I will
take it all off the table that's all
thank you all right one of the coolest
Parts about Dave Chappelle's Firehouse
remodel is that he's technically opening
up a restaurant alongside the comedy
club according to the plan submitted to
the Yellow Springs Planning Commission
Chappelle is opening up a restaurant
called Firehouse eatery that will be
open seven days a week and the attached
comedy club called live from Yellow
Springs with the club just being 120
seats and only open four nights a week
it's dope that there's also a restaurant
attached that comedy enthusiasts can
attend when there's no shows going on or
demand for a ticket is too hot but I
don't know how many hotels they have in
Yellow Springs probably build a hotel
yeah dude become the Monopoly and the
neighbor's gonna complain they're
strange kill the neighbors
who cares Dave why can't you think
immediately with the perfect answer yeah
yeah so his that spot's going to be it's
gonna be interesting if more comics
start doing this buying and opening
clubs this entire idea and plan in
general to open up your own club make it
state of the art run it exactly how you
want give Ohio comedians more stage time
and showcase more comedy in general is
another reason why Dave Chappelle is one
of the Bonafide greats using his
personal influence to create something
that benefits his entire art form
instead of only seeking personal gains
is pretty rare in the world of celebrity
and entertainment but it seems to be the
norm for comedians with two of the most
powerful comics in the industry recently
becoming club Owners there's no denying
that the future of Comedy is in great
hands and as a fan that's gotta make you
excited guest spots from last week your
mom's house had on Johnny Mitchell two
bears one cave was Tom Segura and Ryan
sickler Ryan sickler was also on the
Harland Highway kill Tony this week was
with Ian finance and Tony's mom we might
be drunk out on Rosebud Baker nimish
Patel was a guest on Christian chaos
Tommy Pope and Chris O'Connor were on
are you garbage and sugar Shawn O'Malley
was on flagrance Payless Shoes I
remember when I was younger I went down
Argentina I couldn't get lived to save
my life and by the last night I was
looking I was looking for a girl with
like a small deformity like a shorter
leg no no finger missing sounds good I
was like look at girls hands and see
because if it's a pinky nobody's gonna
notice my dick will look at least this
much bigger and but she knows yeah
[Music]
no but I found a girl that uh was fat
but she had one of those things that
was a one of those dicks and then they
get hard it's so much more fun uh yeah
no no she just had one of those like um
Slims or whatever girl or whatever yes
so and and when when I took it off I
mean the seams were like terrible it's
like open up one of those mattresses
they ship you yeah
yeah it was an insane situation yeah
anyway this past weekend with the Yvonne
was a solo episode The Joe Rogan
Experience had on Steven Wright whiskey
Ginger talked with Jay Pharoah Chris
gethard was on the Honeydew Mike
vacchione was on stavy's World Mark
Maron was on the blocks podcast and
Cipher sounds was on you know what dude
before the pandemic the city was
thriving
gentrification [__] it up as far as
the flavor what are you talking about
what you talking about Willie said
gentrification [__] up the flavor a
little bit Yeah but I don't like that no
no you like the safety I like gays I
love gays I love games but I say we
unleash gays all over the world and
throw gays in Buffalo make buffalo fun
absolutely throw gays in Cleveland
remember when no gays in Chicago we'll
clean it up every fast food joint used
settle down with it as far as brand new
stand-up specials they're either out
right now or coming out soon Chris
Porter there's no money in babies is on
YouTube Lewis Black tragically I need
you is also out on YouTube as well as me
Miss Patel lucky Lefty it's 24 karat
gold
I'm one of the most Indian nut possible
it's also a Bluetooth speaker
anyone want to connect
I'm kidding it's obviously not Bluetooth
speaker it's made out of silicone the
same thing breast implants are made out
of
that's right I got a titty in my balls
also there's been a ton of comedians
announcing new tour dates on their
Instagrams recently including Mark
Norman Tony Hinchcliffe Sam Morel
Rosebud Baker and even Daniel Tosh who
just announced a new tour of the
Southern States called the sweet tea
tour Instagram is usually a pretty good
place to keep up with comedians tour
dates and schedule changes it's also a
good place to follow joke world if
you're a fan of funny podcast Clips also
speaking of our Instagram if you've dm'd
us looking for free joke World stickers
and have not received any yet please
fill out the form titled free stickers
that's located in our accounts bio turns
out way too many people wanted their
free joke World stickers and were dming
us and it was just getting flooded and
we couldn't stay organized and I wanted
to make sure that every single person
who wants a free sticker from us gets
one so now there's a form to fill out
it's in the link in our bio that's it
thanks for watching
at joke world
did it
and the world is wrld
[Music]